did you know that you don't have to pay
taxes you could move to another country
and pay zero taxes legally you might
have already seen my interview with
wealthy expat who does exactly this for
you they've helped over 500 crypto
investors and entrepreneurs like Iman
gaji lower their taxes down to zero
percent legally and you could do this
too in as little as two weeks wealthy
expat will hold your hand through the
entire process setting you up in a
tax-free country like Dubai with the
help of tax experts lawyers and
accountants if you're interested in
paying zero percent taxes make sure to
book a free call with wealthy expat
using my link in the description below I
hope you enjoyed this insightful
interview please don't forget to hit the
like button and subscribe hey guys and
welcome back to the Leia hail pen show
today is going to be a great one I am
joined with former YouTuber now Rambler
live streamer and more commonly known
for his free spirited and supposedly
controversial opinions about men and
women and Society at large snico Welcome
to the show how are you today I'm good
free spirit it makes it sound like I'm
in my whole face oh my God no boss CEO
Queen but that was a good introduction I
I heard you talking before you do sound
like a news woman like you're gonna read
the weather this is much better though
it's good that you switched up your
journalism and now you're doing this
yeah I was doing journalism but then I
was like it felt a little bit too
matrixy for me I couldn't deal with like
being tied around the neck to like the
news so now I'm a bit more free-spirited
but not in there in a good way in a good
way exactly yeah it's good to finally
speak with you we met randomly at a
smoothie shop I ran into you I go there
all the time and then you randomly came
up to me I have been reacting to your
videos for a while so I was like oh [__]
I didn't mean to uh I just didn't expect
to see you it was random I didn't know
you lived here especially in that same
area and keep doing your street
interviews I like reacting to that it's
easy content anybody out there watching
make some NPC Street interviews it's
easy I love reacting to it it's the most
fun videos too so keep doing it oh I'm
glad you like it they're actually one of
the most comfortable videos to do I mean
maybe you probably have a different
experience when you go out but because
I'm like Smiley and I love it I love it
yeah yeah well they think that I'm like
gonna be on their side and then I switch
it up and I play Devils yeah and then
they give me a look and we both just
know that I've like punked them like
you're not one of us yeah I kind of get
that too because I'm a minority so
they're like they especially especially
you did one where it's like
um he's violent towards minorities and
women and like minorities so I get that
the NPCs was like oh he's one of us
because he's not a straight white man
but then they see I I kind of like
making them uncomfortable and making
them feel stupid you feel bad you're
like what about that I'm like nah you're
dumb yeah dummy that's amazing well no
one can really react to it because I'm
already giving the reaction that
somebody else would give in the
interview yours is like a great way for
me to like fall out of my chair or call
him a bot or NPC that's amazing but
you've recently been banned so like talk
me through that you've been taken off
YouTube where have you been banned how
did that happen did you have any
warnings or anything the craziest one
was I had three strikes and a lot of
people are speculating to why they think
it was um some misogyny or some content
but in fact it was what they don't talk
about and it's really alarming to me
that so many commentary channels so many
people are like celebrating the ban or
or talking about her speculating why
it's very clear about it I had covered
misinformation election misinformation
and science election misinformation wait
wait what the hell the 2020 election
well I mean is this on YouTube yeah so
let's just not right so you don't even
want to say and you have to push back to
say that I mean you we don't know what
your opinions are but that's why I got
one of the strikes and the last one was
cyber bullying so two misinformation and
one cyber bullying it had nothing to do
with mentioning other creators it had
nothing to do with being too wild or too
crazy two misinformation strikes which
should be alarming enough the fact that
you can get deleted for saying the wrong
thing not even in terms of insulting but
just the wrong opinion the wrong is is
insane and what people don't talk about
at all they don't they think that was
just been on YouTube I was banned on
Tick Tock Twitter Twitter I'm gonna get
back hopefully but twitch was the
craziest one because switch they just
banned me because they didn't align with
my ideology I didn't do I didn't violate
any terms of service I had never
streamed on Twitch after I was banned on
YouTube I started streaming there and
within a week I was banned and they
emailed me saying it was band of Asian
but I had never made an account before
wow I appealed it and then they said
nope you can't come on so basically it's
just they probably were watching what I
was doing they said no you're not gonna
they banned me before I even violated
any terms of service because like that I
was probably going to so you don't think
obviously these aren't legitimate like
there's no there's no there's absolutely
no real reason Twitter it was because I
challenged somebody to a fight Tick Tock
was just repeated guidelines and but it
doesn't matter you don't really need an
account it's it was a bad decision for
me to even make a twitch I have still
have over 5 billion views on Tick Tock
just from people um posting the clip so
it's fine you don't need an account I'm
still there I first saw you actually on
um on Tick Tock um I saw you doing that
with the eyes there you go yeah you
don't have them I don't have them okay
the eyelashes yeah the the printed on
CVS extensions that go they look like
Shades they look like curtains on top of
your head they look like you make your
eyelids heavy I don't understand how
girls do that sometimes they touch your
eyebrows literally and I always look at
this and for some reason girls think
it's really I don't know why they do it
I've never just it's really distracting
I can't look away from it that's what I
think every time they blink
it's like a Disney cartoon I could hear
the cartoon sound effect and that does
well yeah well
I'm fresh and fair
enough about women the the way that you
speak about women is so interesting
because I agree with you but you speak
about women in a way that like is
actually quite new to me
um because you'll the like the eyelashes
you know saying predicting what women
will say like I don't know girls like
that like that's why I'm so fascinated I
feel like you guys think every single
woman out there is this archetype of you
know the fake eyelashes Boss [__] kind
of vibe I don't know no that's the
social media world so that does really
what girls who are obsessed with clout
are aren't chronically on Tick Tock or
Instagram or they exist for that how
many hours a day do you think you're on
tick tock not a lot no like but there's
some girls that will wake and fall
asleep to tick tock and if they're
obsessed with that they have only fans
girls who are in that world all think a
certain way and they're very predictable
and it's very easy to talk about but in
my live stream for example I I have a
conspiracy night I get into money what's
going on behind the scenes crypto I talk
about Bitcoin what happened with the FTX
what the election I'd like to talk about
the truth and that's why I really think
they banned me because I was funneling
people in from Tick Tock talking about
women and being predicting simple-minded
you know to
that type of content does really well to
reach the Matrix people to get the
normies everybody on Tick Tock knows me
which I realize not a lot of people know
none of them know about Rumble my live
stream numbers have decreased since
coming over it's it's starting to
improve but I am known a lot in the in
the short form content space because I I
know how to get attention so when I
react to like NPCs I scream or like fall
out of the chair when I'm reacting or
like talking to women it's like like
just simple jokes that everyone goes
haha he's making fun of the girl and
then I try to funnel them in here and
tell you the truth and red pill you so
it's just a good way to get a lot of
traction because nobody's gonna like
want to go on Tick Tock and see somebody
talk about the FTX or Bitcoin dipping to
16 no one cares you have to get their
attention yeah no that's so much sense
so okay why did you think they banned
you what was the big situation the big
conspiracy here
I think it was waking up a lot of people
I was growing so fast and I was calling
all out I was calling out a lot of
people and I think I
I pointed out a flaw in the system and
how I I think I just exposing the
brainwashing that's going on with Gen Z
and with the Millennials and you could
say I send you a graphic of the eight
people who have all made hit piece
videos on me they literally look exactly
the same I don't know if I'll show you
right now
um I think it was a lot of reasons and I
was just pointing out on Twitch for
example you could sit in a hot tub and
be naked and like bounce your boobs off
the side of the and just sit there and
collect money and
yeah you didn't know that have you never
been on Twitch twitch is absolutely it's
pretty much it's disgusting and they
Market it towards kids because it's
video games I can't believe yeah it's
supposed to be pretty good but girls
will literally sit I can't believe
you've never heard about this we'll sit
half naked in the tub bikini on and just
sit there and like they'd be like oops
let me get the folder from the back and
they walk and then their butts in this
Frame and stuff like that and they
encourage synth Behavior they want you
to be a simple you know the word simp is
banned on Twitch is it so I actually had
no idea that the word simp was banned on
Twitch I'm against all types of
censorship even when the speech offends
me so this is why I want to tell you
about an alternative internet which is
being built called tominet it's a
decentralized parallel internet where
anyone in the world regardless of the
government restrictions can access the
Tommy net web browser basic human rights
like freedom of speech privacy and
Freedom of Information is at the heart
of what I discuss on this podcast and
Tommy's principles now let's get back to
finding out why the word simp was banned
it's banned you can get permanent band
for saying the word simp because their
whole clientele are simps they want you
to be weaker they want you to be Dumber
so that you stay and you give all your
money to this website if you have strong
men they're not going to come back and
watch gaming videos and hot tub people
they're going to do something else with
their life but to have everybody program
and watching this mindless drone content
forever you have to be weak and stupid
so I was starting to wake people up I
was starting to inspire people I was
screaming and I was like telling people
similar stuff to what you're talking
about how they're trying to mask in a
lot as women and feminize men I was
exposing a lot of that nature and it was
becoming a problem I was growing so fast
I had a million subscribers on my main
channel before I started streaming and
then when I started streaming my second
Channel Grew From 150 000 to 900 000 in
three months all the views on Tick Tock
and people were coming in and I was just
able to roast all these people and every
single commentary channel was upset at
me and I could just make one live stream
and like just go back and forth between
their videos I feel like I was starting
to like break through the programming on
YouTube and on these mainstream
platforms and they had to do something
about it especially when you start
getting that type of attention then you
start talking about the election and
about covid and about like vaccines and
stuff like that I don't you might need
to censor that word magic medicines on
the magic medicines if you become a
problem and they need to paint this
picture of you and so all these
commentary channels who pretend to be
about free speech and who pretend to be
about the truth they'll make it that I'm
a incel misogynistic person when I'm
really talking about stuff that's way
bigger than just men and women what's
really fascinating is that you're so
young and like you're awake to all of
this I don't understand how you're awake
to it and you've been talking about this
stuff since you since you were even
younger right like you were like a
teenager you've been making videos since
I was 14. so they deleted all of that
all my strikes are on my second Channel
my main channel that was just doing
videos on I had been doing since I was
14 I had no strikes and they removed all
of it not only did they ban my main
Channel they banned my second shot my
third channel that had no strikes and
even any fan Channel that I had no
association with just somebody with
snico in the channel banned permaband
and then it's a violating Community
guideline and they didn't they just
wanted to get rid of me completely but
these are the I wanted to show you this
because I thought it was extremely funny
these are eight people and you could put
the graphic up here eight people who
have all made hit piece videos on me and
this is what I'm talking about when you
kind of break through the code and they
get mad because I make fun of their
appearance but the reason I make fun of
your appearance is because you all look
exactly the same I can look at you and
tell you what you think about the
booster shot who you voted for the fact
that you have gender pronouns in your
bio your opinion on crypto or how your
the gym is a waste of time you probably
take antidepressants and when I can
figure that out just by looking at you
becomes a problem because then people
see oh maybe I don't need to be a weak
soy boy simp watching hot tub Gamers all
day yeah no it's insane they literally
all look the same exactly the same they
all look like they don't take care of
themselves they all look weak they all
look like women to be honest
fat women unattractive women they look
like trans women yeah and but the the
funny part is they're all commentary
channels on the Ed they've all they've
literally made documentaries about me I
you think I'm exaggerating there's like
three hour four hour every single it was
getting to the point where I was live
streaming every day they'd make a try to
pay me as a misogynist and then sell
they would go back to my childhood they
would cross analyze and then they would
Tweet stuff like I can't believe I had
to watch so much garbage content to
someone give me props like oh my God
thank you for doing a good service and
watching all those garbage why were you
watching hours of garbage content
imagine investing that much time into
something that you supposedly hate it
makes no sense
but yeah I've always been watching and
and trying to get to the truth since I
was a little kid I've been really Keen
to [__] and similar to you I wanted
to be a journalist at one point but then
everybody in that school was kind of
talking about the same stuff that like
Huffington posts and that will work it's
all woke they train you in school the
journalism majors in school train you to
be a woke journalist it's like I don't
want to go if I'm trying to seek truth
then there's no way that everybody's
gonna have the same ideology so I wanted
to do it myself and my frame of
reference or My Philosophy with
journalism or with seeking truth is uh
seek truth through funny that's what I
have in my bio I've always related to
people and I've always attained the idea
that the truth is what's funny if you
can have everybody on the same page if
you're in a room of people if you could
bring your self-esteem down to one level
then everybody's in agreement on
something and you found some level of
Truth like when you are boosting my
self-esteem by saying the free-spirited
sneako and I say it sounds like I'm in
my whole face it's like bringing down
self-esteem again and then we can we can
have a discussion about it and I think
that's the best way to come communicate
and connect with people I think stand-up
comedians can put the ideas of the
complicated ideas of the world if you
can condense that into a joke it's
something that sticks in my head forever
I remember
Louis CK for example had this joke about
even Jordan Peterson talked about Lucy K
how to joke about everybody going out
Tiger Woods and Charlie Sheen and these
celebrities for sleeping with a lot of
women and cheating on their wives and
like you can't believe you would do that
Tiger Woods it's like you you would
never know what it's like to be Tiger
Woods Tiger Woods he hits the ninth hole
and then he has a busload of Swedish
women waiting for him and that really
put into into context like all these
people writing articles or like saying I
can't believe you have no idea what it's
like and that I always remember those
and it it sticks in my head and reminds
me what reality is
but even making videos at 14 is so young
you must have had something which
triggered you in a way or you must have
like a moment or like a red pilled
moment which made you think I actually
need to you know ask questions like none
of this makes sense you must have had a
moment or something
the red pill moment was
maybe always being told in school that
something was wrong with me that I I was
crazy at ADHD or something like that the
teacher's always insisting that I was a
bad person and then really like deep
down knowing that I'm not bad or knowing
that my intentions were pure
if I if I know that my intentions were
good which they usually always are if
I'm trying to make somebody laugh or I'm
trying to then I know I'm not a bad
person I think if you're intentional in
the wrong place then you deserve
criticism but I was always getting
criticized for like but I was just
trying to be funny I didn't I don't want
to do my homework like it did it's not
there's nothing I'm not a bad person
because I don't want to do my homework
it's just there's a better use of my
time how are you going to tell me what
to do with my time or they'd shame me
for not paying attention in church or in
class like but church is really boring
I'm sitting there sitting kneeling
sitting down doing the same songs every
day listening to somebody who doesn't
know anything about life who has no life
experience tell me a sermon every single
day when you've never had a wife like
why should I listen to you and asking
questions or challenging ideas that were
told that you're supposed to believe
people called me a bad person for when I
was very young and I just chose to not
believe them and chose to believe my
intentions rather than somebody else
deciding what my fate was what about
your parents were they do did they sort
of just go along with the usual thing or
did they inspire you to ask more
questions they
are part of the Matrix but they're
starting to question their realities
more and I helped them when I was
younger questioning a lot of those
things and even at this point my my dad
is starting to send me stuff about the
FTX trading and about how they're money
laundering in Ukraine and how they're
funneling money from crypto scams into
the Democratic party to push the liberal
agenda he's sending me stuff about the
world economic forum and about the
globalist agenda that's going on about
how the CCP is working with Tick Tock to
brainwash America it's like stuff like
that I'm like yo this is pretty base and
at first he was like no go to school do
that like he was a really Matrix ideas
which is natural for a parent because a
parent knows that that's the safest
route for their child it's way riskier
and your parents are probably the same
way or the people around you probably
the same way when you wanted to leave
journalism to do your own thing like no
to get a safe job say in the news of
course it's gonna be and that's not a
bad that's not bad advice for most
people that will work it's harder to
break out of that and do your Do Your
Own Thing
so I understand why they wanted me to do
that but also I was shamed a lot and
especially the last two years I'm sure a
lot of people watching can understand
the amount of guilt that a lot of people
felt for questioning what was happening
was insane and all those people just
went right back like the eight feminist
soy boy looking people were the people
that giving you dirty looks in the
grocery store you know
it's about it we all go back to
normal
to this the programming stopped they
stopped telling you in the news that it
was a big deal so everyone just moves on
to the next thing now they have Ukraine
in their bio they have BLM in their bio
they gave up and nobody even critically
thinks about that anymore we're so
outraged we live in an outraged world
that we move from one thing to the next
and we're at a point where we really
need to sit and reflect about what
happened in the last two years the fact
that everybody can flip a switch that
quick be so outraged shame you for
wanting to spend time with your grandma
go home for Christmas and then
completely move on to the next thing
I and a lot of you watching will feel
the same thing if you question anything
if you didn't want to follow the agenda
if you wanted to live the way you wanted
to live they shame the [__] they called
you a terrible person they said you are
killing my family by walking outside
seriously now when you say that it
sounds insane but that's what happened
and we need to spend time to to really
think about how quickly we can all be
manipulated by the media yeah it's so
insane um the amount of people wearing
masks and the social pressure and the
the confidence and the courage that it
actually takes to not wear a mask like I
was in London during the whole lockdown
and everybody on the train was wearing a
mask and I would sit there without a
mask and that is really difficult like
that is so difficult because the social
pressure the pressure to conform is is
unbelievable and I think you're right
it's incredible it's always the same
people they look the same they have BLM
they have the flag they have all the
flags and in their bios the vaccines
um it's insane how it's all the same
people um but what was it what was it
like in New York because I know New York
is pretty well it was pretty similar to
London I went to London during the the
pandemic a couple times too and I was on
I was on the tube and even then uh one
guy I was just no mask I don't care like
people give me dirty looks and stuff
like that and one guy came and he gave
me um a mask with a bunch of gay pride
flags on it and Lynn sis and it's okay
and I was traveling did you wear it I I
would you wore a sneaker I did I did
because then it was getting pressure and
there were even police there were police
coming give you fines and also I'm a
foreigner so if I if I get a fine or
something like that I go to jail then I
gotta get they just I'll let you off in
the forest the 400 thing like it's it's
not you know okay like I'm more careful
here I don't get deported someone I
don't want to get deported but I didn't
I didn't fully do it I did the chin one
you know he was nice about he wasn't
being a dick he's like oh here and it
was like the flat the hearts with the
front I'm like this guy cares I'll make
him happy and I did the chin one thumbs
up and he's like and by the time he saw
that I wasn't wearing it I got off the
train but but even before a week before
I was in Barcelona they had cops with
dogs on the train like giving out
tickets so it's do you really is it
really worth this Civil Rights Movement
right now but in in New York it was a it
was it was pretty bad probably the same
as London yeah I was there um when you
reacted to the video I was there a few
weeks ago and there's actually no normal
people left like I feel like Miami is
the only Spot Miami and Dubai is the
only sport where there's normal people
everybody is either and I'm gonna get
like attacked for saying this but
everybody's either super fat or like you
know changing their genders or just you
know piercings everywhere tattoos all
over everybody looks weird have you
noticed that everybody just looks weird
these days yeah and it's funny that they
get piercings and they dye their hair
and they add gender pronouns to be
unique and then they're the same as
everybody else it's like you you can
look at somebody with a dyed hair and
you know all their opinions you see the
septum piercing you know they're a free
spirit you got the Ukraine flag to be a
good citizen it's like you're just being
programmed but there's a lot of people
listening right now that are upset that
you said that there's people in rural
places in America or even the the brexit
people in the UK they're like we're not
like this most people are are I think
it's the really loud uh minority yeah
it's the people who scream the loudest
and who are walking around in the
streets in different in this in major
cities I don't think that's everybody I
still have hope that there's non-npcs
out there do you have um like an overall
take on what happened over the last two
years like why did they lock us down for
something which has um like 99.9
survival rate and force us to take
medicines which don't work and are now
supposedly dangerous
I'm not even sure can I say um NWO on
YouTube
NWO yeah you just say as NWO okay oh New
World Order yes yes and I think they're
prefer they're preparing us for an a new
Global agenda
and this was the first test if you look
at there was conferences where
billionaires sat together and there we
started preparing they were outlining
how they were going to keep us compliant
they're starting to prepare us to have
you were talking about about having a
carbon footprint and how much money we
can spend and how they can we could have
walk points on a social score and that
you could see that with um if you look
at what's happening in China it's pretty
much what's gonna happen in the next
five ten years in the west because all
the government control that we thought
was crazy happened in the west and China
right now you can't even go on certain
roads if you don't scan a QR code in the
sky and show that you have a vaccine
passport that's the real thing that's
happening they are still quarantining
people they have giant tents where
they're they're testing everybody they
are trying to keep us all as controlled
as possible they want to limit the food
supply they just ultimately want to keep
us as slaves as Citizens and the rich
are going to get extremely richer and
it's easier for them to enjoy life if
they keep us all as cheap in his
peasants and they they realize they
could do that by controlling us with
fear manipulation and they can silence
anybody who speaks out against that so
as long as everybody is controlled by
fear as long as we're canceling each
other as long as we're yelling about BLM
and a bunch of [__] and we're
yelling about race or nonsense that keep
us controlled at the bottom and we're so
distracted and we don't see what's
really happening then they can do
whatever they want and this the past few
years was the first step in that new
agenda yeah I agree with you I actually
heard today that um I think like seven
banks in New York are all testing um a
central bank digital currency as of
today they've partnered with the fed and
the Federal Reserve and they're they're
yeah they're working on their
programmable money
um and they're going to see how far they
can take it which is absolutely insane
but um let's let's go to the men and
women topic because I feel like this is
a lot softer than well nobody but I feel
like they're the same because I feel
like they're integrated because it's all
about like
depopulation repelling the Sexes you
know less less um less less population
easier to easier to control but let's
start with women because like we spoke
about earlier you you laugh at them a
lot online and it's very enjoy enjoyable
that's how I first found you so what
would you say one of the biggest
problems
is with women right now young girls
is they want the Privileges of being a
woman while simultaneously wanting the
Privileges of being a man and you can't
have both men are out here we know that
being a man is what we're supposed to do
we don't also want to be women but girls
want to be pretty girls and they want us
to hold the door open and pay for the
date and then also be the boss
and then also be in charge and then also
get all the same right and they they
want equal pay which is the wage Gap is
[__] but they want to have all the
same equal opportunities like okay well
take out the trash no they're like why
can't I be a CEO I'm like okay why can't
you be a garbage man no it's gross and
icky it's you can't pick and choose you
need to understand that we have
different roles and we have different
and it
women don't want to be seen as weak
which is the problem is that a lot of
women want their their envious of male
power they are jealous of the fact that
we can be in charge and we can lead but
they don't want to embrace their
feminine nature while also dressing up
and looking like they're a pretty girl
so I think girls most girls now because
of social media are an ego battle in
their head and it's not all their fault
see I make fun of girls a lot of time
for that and then when I have these
debates it's like well why am I going to
be the girls will say well why can't it
be how can I be feminine if the men that
I'm around are extremely feminine and
that's that's true a lot of men don't
understand that they need to play their
role as a man as well and that's why
these women are acting extremely
masculine the average guy cannot really
put up with the average woman anymore
because
all these women think that they deserve
the top men because of social media they
all compare their relationships to the
richest man the most famous men and I
want that I want a Birkin but most guys
will never be able to afford that so
we're not living in reality we're
constantly comparing we constantly think
that there's something else that we can
strive for but women are more
materialistic so they have a harder time
settling I think men the average man
will just be happy with the hug but
women just don't know how to as soon as
they as soon as they're with one of
those high-level men or women don't know
how to ever step down they don't know
how to downgrade men are just like let's
be like they'll settle okay you're fine
you can cook okay come here women have a
women have ego that that is not talked
about enough and that's why I can make
so much content about it
you said that women think they deserve
more than they actually do deserve so
what kind of woman
deserves you know the top kind of man
that we're talking about
a woman that can balance out and Inspire
and
be to see the common answer is like you
have to be the peace but I think it's
much more than that I think you have to
inspire you need to motivate you need to
be the correct balance you still need to
have the correct ideas you need to
challenge I think I I don't think a lot
of guys in the space talk about that
enough but
a good woman can check you a good woman
is smart and knows how to
give some ideas as well how to play her
role not just as the mother or as the
nurturer but also
how to be the correct person to
give inspiration
I think that's uh a role that that women
Overlook a lot of the time they think
that if they watch a lot of this content
they'll think that they just need to
cook and they just need to be submissive
and feminine that's part of it but
there's something to to challenging a
man and
how if if you do add that challenge you
could uplift each other
mentally because I yeah I do always hear
that it's no just be submissive like it
gets boring it's like what are you going
to talk about I don't think that people
in the space talk about that enough like
I'd like I would like to talk to my
woman I would like to have conversations
I would like to
Inspire each other challenge each other
and I I don't just want you to be an
empty airheaded maid I want to to hear
what you have to say too that that
matters a lot of people misconstrue the
red pill ideas as if um women are just
objects and everything and I can
understand why that's happened a lot of
people get in this like I could have 20
women and they're just a lot of guys too
like that when they get to that level
they don't even want to put up with a
woman they just want to work and then
I've met some like
multi-multi-millionaires and their
girlfriends are [__] airheaded like
nothing up there and that's fine they're
dumb and they'll they'll be happy
they'll have a happy life but I
personally would get extremely bored
with that I wouldn't respect her after a
while just like just [__] dummy what
is she doing she's just there with her
apron I can I can hire a maid I could
just a maid to [__] that's it a lot of
guys will will like that and that's a
form of settling because they don't want
to be challenged and they don't want to
uplift themselves anymore but I I always
want to keep growing and I want to keep
learning so I I value an intellectual
woman I think think that that's not
spoken about enough do you think you'll
still have that
Pennies from now you say go single 10
years from now and you're a
multi-millionaire billionaire do you
think that'll still be your same
I hope so I wouldn't want to give up on
that and I would like to watch this
again and if I went back on that then
that means to some degree I settled if I
just want a woman who's just going to be
there and stroke my ego and cook then I
think I gave up on a big aspect of life
that can be accessed if you're with the
person that can inspire you that's a
great answer so so what's the problem
with men then today
with well with a lot of the the high
value men and multi-millionaires who
they get tired with putting up with
women so they'll just get that
um a woman who's just there but I think
the problem with with all men yeah with
masculinity in general like why like why
did you I agree with your tweet I
they're the biggest crime in society is
uh how they're how they're trying to
feminize men I think like the picture
that I showed you that's a giant problem
and
they want you to become that like I want
every young man if there's a teenager
watching this they want you to become a
pasty pale looking nerd soy boy who has
the same opinions and they want you to
be awoke nothing who thinks the gym is
bad for you they want you to take
antidepressants they want you to be weak
the face of all those people that I
showed you is the face of people who
will never get banned people that they
put on the training page people that
have the biggest platforms because they
never get sound so they never get
challenged those are people who are
echoing the same Matrix that's being
purported by the elites they are just
puppets for the richest people they
don't realize it they think that they're
being social justice Warriors when
they're really just by programming
people to think nonsense and they're all
being manipulated by having a sense of
moral superiority but that's not most
men
that's
I again that's the internet age and
that's a lot
the problem with most men
is I guess the balance of that because
you can go too far down the rabbit hole
of being a feminine sore boy or you
could also be overly masculine to
balance that out and I think there does
need to be some
about some bounce you need to be able to
tap into both but
you it's tough because if men men a lot
of time they realize that if you show
your vulnerable side to a woman then
they'll take advantage of that so they
just want to be completely hard-hitting
all the time and that's why they don't
want a woman to challenge them because
they don't want to be taken advantage of
I think the the problem is trying to
find that perfect balance well I the
reason I made the tweet that the
feminization of men is the greatest
crime against humanity is because I
believe that without strong men Society
just crumbles what we saw over the last
two years I just I just don't think that
would have happened if we had more
strong men standing up and fighting even
the men that I used to regard as strong
I saw them just like bowing down to
everything that was happening
um so I feel like tyranny can come when
the men are weak
you're right you're right completely
that's why
they don't want you that's why they want
you to become weaker because that's the
biggest threat is having strong men to
lead is the biggest threat to any
systems of power so yeah I agree with
you completely I think we have a very
similar world view there's nothing I'm
going to tell you that that you haven't
thought or heard about I'd follow your
social medias so what's your take then
on porn and video games because it's the
worst it's it's I actively tell it's the
worst thing for young men is and that's
why I tell people to use social media as
a tool to make money use it for your own
gain don't be used by social media
because if you look at my explore page
for example I always show this to my
stream my explore page is just straight
up softcore porn and some people say
like that's what you look up that's what
they know you're interested in they they
might know based on the algorithm that
that's what I'm interested in but I
don't watch porn and I actively only use
social media to make money and if I
didn't then you could easily go down
that rabbit hole and scroll and then see
like it's it's they'll show sex on their
explore I could show you you know what
I'm talking about
um well they'll show sex like off to the
side or sometimes you don't know open
your Excel page let me see it's it's
disgusting because that's not my explore
page what's yours like a bunch of crypto
uh let me see can I have my phone a sec
to see all my explore Pages because I
actually don't know about a year ago
just a bunch of babies and it's not
anymore I really don't know why that's
the case let me see what's my explore
page
oh mine is mine is uh we have Andrew
Tate obviously
do I have some hot men and hot women I
mean mine's not mine's not that exciting
I mean mine's not that exciting okay
yeah mine's not that bad either the
Signal's bad in here okay but I went on
Tick Tock today because I was trying to
do some Market reasons I don't have Tick
Tock I don't use Tick Tock but I was
trying to see like how my recent streams
were doing from Rumble and how the
conversion was doing well on Tick Tock
and then you just see the amount of like
girls will be like my morning yoga
routine and she's just lifting up her
leg up in the sky doing a split right in
front of the camera yeah well like I'm
telling you what they put on the front
pages twitch hot tub streamers they're
trying to that that's the best way to
manipulate men is is with these images
were visual creatures and porn can ruin
your life legitimately it's a drug and
people don't talk about it like that
video games too could be extremely
addictive and basically those two things
and I like that you group them together
because they're the same media that just
really hits your dopamine and gives you
a false it makes you feel successful
without doing anything you get
levels you level up in a video game you
get the high score and porn you feel
like you [__] a girl who but you
didn't do any of the work to do it so it
makes you it gives you the success
without doing any of the work which is
very detrimental to men and porn is the
worst thing ever you need to quit doing
it it's no November what are we like
halfway through stay strong halfway
there fellas
keep going halfway there I don't know
when it's being posted
November maybe no not December keep
going
and do the new year and 2023 now we're
totally covered perfect
um there's also like other dynamices who
men and women which you speak about a
lot I see on fresh and fit a lot um and
it's kind of the supposed double
standard that um men can sleep with a
bunch of women and that's okay and women
can't sleep with a bunch of men that
wouldn't be okay so can you talk to me
about what what the difference is
between men being [__] and women being
[__] well like why is it not the same
well first let's start and say
men don't get offended by being called
[__] that doesn't hurt if but if a
woman if I called you a [__] that would
hurt your feelings that would that would
make you feel bad but if you say like
why can't men be [__] like no one
cares like you can't [__] shame a man no
guys ever felt shame about that
the double standard is I can get 20
women pregnant but a woman can only get
pregnant once in a year so but I've been
thinking a lot about this and
yes it's different because a man has to
earn it a man has to get to the point
where he could be with a lot of women
women could just literally right now you
could walk outside open up your legs and
someone will do it you know I can't walk
outside so disgusting it's true your
legs and someone will do it if someone
will be in there in five minutes there
will be somebody in there but if I walk
outside with my dick I'm going to jail
that's the difference unless you're
trans by the way because a guy in
England by the way he um well a trans
woman got up on stage and actually
started playing the piano with his deck
like he's a woman yeah no no wait wait
no it's a man it's a biological man it's
a woman wait no what do you mean oh are
you playing with me because I'm too
confused I can't look what it's coming
on it so yeah unless you're trans and
you have the exception but sorry
continue
I think that I've been trying to get
closer to God into religion and
a lot of guys need to indulge in that
and be [__] to get over it a woman I
don't really think needs to do that
because a woman there's no satisfaction
of being a [__] you can just you just
do it but a man it's like once you get
to that point where you can be with a
lot of women you need to get out of your
system but
being closer to God and being a
well-rounded man is is not acting
and not indulging in Hedonism which is
chasing hoes or with these Miami girls
who like I'm a girl but or like
sometimes I'll be hanging out with the
girls like and she does only fans it's
like I spent six hours talking to this
girl she just has nothing about her
there's no personality so
it's the the point of being with the
woman is starting a family is
establishing a relationship and
indulging in short-term sex or these
one-night stands it's ultimately a way a
giant waste of time and you're doing it
to stroke your ego I think that's why in
the past when I was really indulging in
that it wasn't that much better than sex
with the same girl but I was trying to
be with a lot of women because it was
like it was like a video game it's like
a challenge like did that did that and
I'd walk around [__] her [__] over
and it would just it would be fun for me
or like be like yo yeah it would be with
my guys and it'd be it would be an ego
stroke but if you really think about how
much time and how much energy and how
much of investment you're spending into
just nothing because there's nothing
accomplished from that the point of sex
is to procreate
it's it's a waste of your energy it's a
waste your time and you could be it
could be much better spent that's
interesting because I I keep pairing men
say you know your 20s just like go
through everything you can
and then early in your 30s you should
you know think about it a bit more who
says that I'll just hear it all the time
I'm 24 and I'm ready to to I I'm coming
to terms that this is it's empty after a
while like I see guys 10 years older who
are doing the same thing I was doing it
like 23 22 I'm like okay when do you
elevate when do you get to the next step
so
but yeah it's it's a very clear
difference it's a very clear difference
but men men have a different
Learning System than women women I think
inherently know that but I think men
need to go through it in order to fully
understand
so I can sit here and say that it's
Hedonism but all the guys who have not
experienced it yet are going to want to
do it
yeah I think I think it's um I think
it's an interesting one especially
because like with this with this red
pilled mentality we keep hearing you can
have 20 wives you can have as many women
as you want you don't think that that
would be satisfying in some way having
as many women as you want just because
you can eventually Maybe
yeah that sounds amazing that sounds
yeah it does but there's there's a
better use of your time like that's not
a very Godly life
but
still you imagine that the den Bilzerian
lifestyle it sounds it does sound
appealing to a lot of guys and I think
I think it's some I think young men need
to hear that a little bit more actually
because of how we're being feminized I I
talk about that a lot because on the
inverse when you see all the soy boys
like shaming you or call it saying toxic
masculinity or trying to make men feel
bad for trying to improve they call it
cringe if a guy's like working on
himself or trying to dress better or
like the the leftist will say it's
cringe if you're like you're on the
grind or like they'll make fun of hustle
culture when it needs to be encouraged
more so ultimately no you're not going
to be satisfied for the rest of your
life with 20 girls in the house they're
pretty much there for you your status
and your money they don't really care
about you but I think it's good
motivation to hear that for young men I
think that it's good on the inverse of
how much they're pushing simp culture
and what they and how much porn in video
games if a guy hears them something like
danville's here I'm like bro that sounds
dope now I want to go get more money now
I want to go improve myself now I want
to start 10 businesses so I can get to
that point and if I do get to that point
or when I do get to that point I'm going
to be like you know what I actually
don't want these 20 girls anyway maybe
I'm good with four
yeah yeah four you know five
to money yeah
nice and that's a good amount yeah
so with all these Bannings going on
social media I know you obviously moved
to rumble what do you think the future
of content creation is are we all just
gonna get banned and then we move to
rumble I mean do we trust Rumble that
they're not gonna
um you know be bought out by uh Cloud
Schwab you know I hope not I don't think
so I know Chris uh Chris pavlovlowski I
think his name is he's a he's a nice guy
I I I've spent time with him it's weird
like being out with him I can't imagine
ever hanging out with Susan from YouTube
so I hope he doesn't sell out I really
think he believes in the message I
really think he believes in free speech
and so if he compromises that the basis
of the website was free speech you know
what's funny I was thinking about this
yesterday because I'm new to rumble and
I've been looking at all at the front
page it's pretty much all political
conservatives it's all Republicans live
streaming does really well and I was
thinking like what's the leftist for
what's the leftist website everything
else it's just YouTube it's just every
single platform they're never gonna have
to go to another website because they're
just allowed that's the page for them
the right people who don't believe in
the the agenda that's being pushed they
have to go to Alternative platforms so
my method for going forward is
capitalizing off of short form content
gen Z's attention span is absolutely
destroyed and I know how to get that
because I have a bad attention span I'm
energetic I'm loud I know how to capture
people's tension in five seconds so like
you when I react to your NPC videos this
is a vial clip anytime you react to an
NPC like why don't you like entertain
I'm like fall out of my chair scream
stuff like that that's always going to
capture it people are going to go wow
cool when you're scrolling that's what's
going to capture your attention so I
know how to do that what I have to do is
funnel that short attention span people
into my stream and into my website so
for the future advice for people who
want to speak about similar subjects not
everybody wants to do this but this is a
good method to follow you need to figure
out how to capture people's attention
quickly and funnel that into long form
content I stream for flat for five hours
every single day so I'm talking but I
can't just be screaming and falling out
of my chair for five hours I need to
have something to talk about so I get
into politics I get into relationships I
talk to different people I interview
people I bring people on the stream I
like to learn different things I talk to
the chat I watch different videos so I I
have good ways to capture an audience
for five hours but I also know how to
bring in new people and you really need
to Triple down on that new people in the
short form content because if they keep
Banning the truth then the leftists and
the the soy boys are going to keep keep
getting promoted but what you need to
realize is those people are getting it's
so easy for them that they don't need to
challenge themselves so automatically
they are boring all the people that I
showed you who have made documentaries
about me cannot get in a debate with me
they don't do it they are afraid they
don't know how to people have literally
spent months making videos about me I'll
be like let's get on a call no I don't
want to they're they're afraid of it so
if you are capable of doing that you
already five steps ahead of them and you
can capture an audience quicker you
could be more captivating uh attention
grabbing entertaining everything that
you need in order to be to capture an
audience but it's way you're supposed to
realize is what do you do with that
audience are you just there to be a
clown are you just there to play video
games and make money personally I love
entertaining I like making people laugh
but I want to elevate and I want to
inspire I think the highest human
achievement you could reach is
inspiration if you can Inspire other
people that's the greatest satisfaction
in life and I I think I realized that
really young it's better than money it's
better than than sex or anything if you
can connect and inspire people that's
what gives me
hope and gives me drive to keep going
and I've realized that seeing this shift
into media and how everybody wants to
get into consecration now these crypto
Millionaires and these business people
these econ people they have a lot of
money they have houses and stuff like
that and they get kind of bored after a
while and they see how the world is
moving and they see how people all these
conversations are getting online and
they want to be a part of it because
having the money after a while it's okay
but inspiring connecting with people
that's a level of satisfaction that a
lot of people have not realized or ever
tapped into and they want to get into
that so you have to be entertaining
though you can't just give value you
can't just like talk to people and
expect them to listen there needs to be
some way to capture their attention the
reason and I know this because when I
was in school I never wanted to listen
the teacher were boring or I I the
priest for example like when I was
saying in church was boring saying
droning on
uh she's uh sleeping and nothing no
disrespect to the church but it was just
really boring so I need to be laughing I
need to be engaged in order to learn I
can't do it without it so I know I
that's my most effective way of teaching
you mentioned that um in school uh that
you know you thought you're like an
outcast because you know you you were
bored you weren't listening you weren't
focusing
um so it's interesting how deep do you
actually think the Matrix goes beyond
men and women because all these kids are
on ADHD pills
um you know I was yeah exactly yeah
you're on ADHD pills I'm sure you
probably don't take them anymore no
exactly so how how deep do you think it
goes
I mean Epstein's Island was exposed and
then everybody moved on to the next
thing I I genuinely think there's a
spiritual warfare going on I think that
they the most powerful people go on
islands and they do sacrificial rituals
with children genuinely I think that
they try to conjure evil to separate
morality from their psyche so that they
can have more power and they don't care
about people that's the reason that
they're able to manipulate vast
majorities billions of people all at
once is because they don't care they
have no morality and in order to
separate empathy morality you need to do
evil acts and also they do these evil
acts to Blackmail each other if they've
all touched and ate a kid then they all
have dirt on each other and they won't
expose what's really going on behind the
scenes of course I've never seen this I
don't have factual evidence for it I
never will I never but there there's
been people who have tried to expose
this and they always have the same fate
I you watch movies like eyes wide
shutter you can see people like who try
to expose like Julian Assange or or
Edward Snowden or what was happening to
Alex Jones and they all repeatedly get
silenced and they get called to Crazy
conspiracy there they get called a
treasonous they just they always have
the same fate or they end up dead in a
forest in Cuba uh what happened to John
McAfee it's always the same fate and
we're getting to the point where it
pretty much has been exposed to Jeffrey
Epstein the most rich and powerful
people were all going to an island and
then he supposedly died in prison which
everybody knows was a lie but we all
moved on and so when I talk about this
people will call me a crazy conspiracy
theorist but then what about Epstein's
what happened there why are these people
all flying out they're the most rich and
powerful people are all going buddy
buddy with somebody who was trafficking
children
and you think that I'm just making this
up when I talk about how they use evil
to become more powerful I really think
it's a spiritual warfare
who who are the people that are actually
doing these bad acts versus the puppets
because I'm unsure if somebody like you
know like Biden for example is a puppet
like to me I think he's a puppet class
Schwab I don't know the leader of the
walekum I don't know whether he's just a
puppet probably somebody else some
nameless person who has trillions of
dollars behind the scenes that will
never know his name and Biden Klaus
Schwab these people that we know about
they are puppets they probably weren't
there they got blackmail on them they
have a video of them touching a kid and
now they have to do whatever the [__]
they say yeah that's what they're we're
not going to know these people a lot of
them behind the scenes and if we do then
then they change their identity they go
to a different country the most rich and
power I don't think we'll ever know that
or they get sacrificed they end up dead
in a prison supposedly they hang
themselves anybody who makes it out of
that becomes a public figure yeah we
won't know them
what's your take on stand back me for
each you think he's a puppet of um The
Establishment who somebody read the CEO
of FTX yeah of course he was I need to
do more tell me about that because I
heard that he was oh the that the fat
dude with the the curly yeah the FDX guy
yeah he was a puppet they probably got a
video of him doing something and so then
he started funneling money to the
Democratic party yeah they probably got
a video from did he flee to Argentina
now no he's in the Bahamas saying
cryptic stuff still not detained not
arrested like he's just chilling there
on his phone tweeting rubbish what do
you think is his fate is he gonna end up
my take is
no because I I personally think that he
that that the powers that be tried to
use FTX as the as a way to infiltrate
crypto so they wanted to have a
regulatory Monopoly on FTX therefore
they control crypto pushing all other
competition out so I feel like they they
funded him I think they funded him I
think he I saw one conspiracy which was
like there's a Mr Maxwell who might be
just Lane Maxwell's father I don't know
but he died in like the 90s or something
nobody knows where his billions went but
then Jeffrey Epstein popped up with all
these billions and then he mysteriously
dies oh who's married or with uh the
daughter of Maxwell gisling thank you
according to pronounce it just lane giz
lane he then just so bear with me
Jeffrey Epstein then dies mysteriously
where do his billions go well he dies
around the same time that Sam bankman
freed just pops up with all these
billions so now sandbagman freed has all
these billions in 2019 which he
supposedly made by Arbitrage trading
Bitcoin for three and a half years you
don't make nine billion dollars in three
years by Arbitrage trading Bitcoin so I
feel like the establishment or whatever
passed him the money to have him as a
front and have him as like this this
puppet for the elites then donates the
money he becomes like the he becomes
like this this the crypto arm for the
establishment so I feel like he's one of
them I don't think they'll unless he
speaks so unless he unless he calls them
all out then I think he could get
epsteined but while he stays silent and
just like disgraced a little bit like
Harvey Weinstein is silent and disgraced
then then I think he'll be fine and I I
otherwise yeah I think he'll be fine
like Barry Madoff was like arrested the
next day
when he when he took everybody's money
so I'm back with freed just chilling
tweeting in the Bahamas like I don't I
don't think I don't think he's gonna get
the justice that he deserves because
he's a puppet of the system does that
make sense
I don't know what did your dad saying by
the way he said um he he was just
throwing surface level stuff and saying
that I need to do more research on it
and he was just like sending me articles
and about he showed me how they were
funneling money into the Democratic
party yeah so so Sam Batman freed was
the second largest don't uh donor to
President Biden's um political campaign
and then FTX set up a bit on the website
where you can then send money to Ukraine
turns out so wait stand back with freed
send money to Biden Biden's
Administration then sent money to
Ukraine billions of dollars Ukraine then
send money to FTX
so it's a circle of money laundering and
all this stuff so that's why I think
like I think Sam I'm afraid is part of
it like I think he's part of the
establishment and he's not going to get
the justice that he deserves
but look what happened to Epstein though
as soon as they become a public figure
they need to make an example of it it's
possible he could have that fate but
I just I just I don't know I just I
don't when when
um when like it becomes like sexual I
think that's when the establishment have
to um detach themselves yeah when like
there's like you know pedophiles were
they all like in a room of 10 people
they had like a 10 person polyamorous
relationship yeah I mean the whole thing
was incestuous so the founder of Alameda
research which is the not the founder
the CEO of animated research which is
the sister company of FTX was his
ex-girlfriend whose father taught at um
MIT where the SEC chairman Gary ginslaw
is a professor at MIT where Sam Baker
freed went to University there it's all
incestuous they all dated someone a bit
like the Maxwell's like everybody's it's
disgusting and yeah I think I don't know
I think it's better just to like buy
Bitcoin and like join Rumble and like
leave the Matrix you know
how much do you I don't want to say I
have but do you think it's going to dip
lower I've been talking to people like
that is it going to go lower than 16. I
think right now we are at such a
temperamental uh it's a weird time it
could go down to five maybe yeah if
there's another Black Swan event like I
think Bitcoin could have bottomed at
around 17 and a half if FTX didn't
happen but there's so much dodgy
dealings happening behind the scenes
that if more stuff comes to light then I
see no reason why it won't go lower I
mean weird stuff is happening with
crypto.com the CEO came out and said
they accidentally sent billions of
dollars of customer funds to gate.io
which is another exchange what do you
mean you accidentally sent billions of
dollars of customer funds you know and
then you see gate.io sending the money
back you can look at it on the
blockchain it's so dodgy so if if
another exchange like [__] up then yeah
I think we're going much lower but I
don't really care I think getting in
under getting in at this price is such a
steal like this time I'll share Bitcoins
at 69 000 people would like pray and
fresh for these prices I know my brother
is extremely happy that bitcoin's very
cheap it's on sale yes massively on sale
buy one get one free literally are you
holding many much crypto yeah I have an
equal amount in ethereum but I wonder
you always talk about Bitcoin is
ethereum some budget what is that okay
so I this is my take results I think
ethereum is World economic Forum like
right so okay several things going on
here vitalik who's the founder of
ethereum is being really
um uh apologetic about Sam bankman freed
like he's not going hard on him Sam
backman freeze tweets I'm sorry vitalik
retweets it he's like being like we
should all be a bit kinder to him no the
guy just stole billions from people so
vitalik is like being very sympathetic
to these people
um they've also just moved from proof of
work to proof of stake I don't know how
technical you are but yeah okay you know
what that is yeah okay so proof of stake
is like really championed by those at
the world economic forum and because of
the energy crisis you know world sorry
proof of work is bad because of the
energy crisis
um because you know the world is
collapsing because climate change and
all that rubbish right so if the world
economic Forum are excited about proof
of stake then I'm not excited about
proof of stake for me like that's just a
red flag at this point nothing that has
come out of what they've done or what
they've said
is is good is legitimate makes
everything that surrounds them is just
dark and and bad in my opinion
um and then also like and then also
um proof of stake is far more
centralized just because you know if you
own more if you have a bigger stake then
you have more control and that's like
the current system that we're in now the
more money you have the more people you
have no ethereum no I hold some but I'm
going to sell it in the bull market like
it will go back up for sure because like
the entire internet is being built on
ethereum right now but that's bad
because they're now rebuilding Society
on the blockchain but which one ethereum
which the world economic Forum probably
having massive stake in and will control
so it's gonna have both though
from like a from like a financial like
investment standpoint yeah but like the
idea is like you want to opt out like
because if they don't have power if they
don't have money and they don't have
their own money they have yours and so
if you remove your money from the banks
and you hold it in a system which is
completely outside of their control they
have nothing
they can't they can't do anything how
are you going to fund Wars they take
your money they print more
they take your money and they fund Wars
well what if you can't print more money
what if they don't have our money to
fund the wars what's preventing them
from another FTX scandal
that's a good question I mean nothing
really
as individuals we have to not give them
the money which means not leaving our
money on a centralized exchange like FTF
can we really win that because they can
just print more money they can they have
complete control over currency if they
wanted to beat the citizens then a
couple trillionaires on an island could
all just print some more money and
invest it in Bitcoin and then do whale
deals behind the scenes and beat all the
normies who are trying to win basically
but that's why we tell everyone to buy
to buy Bitcoin
shut up oh my God
blog Fighters went bankrupt as as we
speak [__] you know who blocked fire no
block fire is centralized exchange that
went bankrupt oh my God this is so bad
[__] I thought we're gonna get okay so
Blockbusters centralized exchange that
we're about to go bankrupt when Celsius
went bankrupt but FTS yeah but FTX
bought them which um bailed them out but
FTX have no money and so since they've
just gone bankrupt block five just gone
bankrupt that's really sad blockfire
they are good people I guess block five
people put their money on their platform
and so is that good for us or bad for us
it's I don't even know it's it's bad for
the crypto space it's a centralized it's
a centralized exchange which is uh well
centralized platform that gives you like
six percent interest on your Bitcoin
it's just gone bankrupt which basically
means that people need to remove their
money from centralized entities and they
need to put their money in Cold Storage
that that's that's to go here so you're
you're buying up you're buying you're
buying crypto yep investing more every
it's pretty cheap right now so I'm gonna
keep putting more money you've just sold
me on more Bitcoin yeah I'm gonna buy a
whole coin as soon as I leave this
podcast perfect yeah we'll help you do
it that's amazing whole coin I have a
couple oh you do yeah don't say that out
loud just pretend you don't have any I
don't have any there you go I have none
yeah you dropped your keys in the water
the in the ocean that's the joke yes
that yeah it's serious okay why can't
you say that
rob you because I'm gonna pick my words
really yes there's that but also like as
as a sovereign individual those at the
top have no right to know what you own
and therefore you owe nothing because
you had crypto but then you lost the
keys and they're at the bottom of the
ocean with all your guns you don't own
guns either they're at the bottom of the
ocean
yeah I have none exactly you have not
broke yeah and you're like triple Jabs
and everything crypto is for hustle
culture toxic masculinity people no we
don't do that just like everything we
just said so just okay just finally then
what would you what kind of advice would
you give to do you think I'm crazy for
that whole spiritual warfare
demon-eating children thing okay so okay
great we grossed we went right to crypto
from demons I'm wondering what your
response on that is okay so like I'm so
open-minded like I I'm down for it you
know I I think it's possible I don't
really think it goes as far as like
eating children
um and like sacrificing children I
definitely think there's like a weird
pedophile ring going on but I think
that's as far as it goes I think
yeah I think the eating children things
a bit far-fetched but the reason I
mentioned David icus because he thinks
that and he thinks that oh really yeah
David Ike thinks that and he thinks
everything that happened in eyes wide
shot is legitimate it's fully real God
right after that movie was released yeah
yeah yeah that's true and um David Ike
also says that the people controlling us
are non-human entities
so I don't know if this is something
those are people yeah he's the lizard
he's the lizard man okay but how do they
become losers are they just not human
okay I'll explain it because I actually
like I think they become inhuman by
doing these rituals and doing stuff that
makes them not human if you eat a kid
then you're not a person anymore your
soul is gone right metaphorically
speaking you're not human anymore that's
that's a good way to separate your soul
from your body is doing the most evil
Act of all time and then you have
absolutely no morality which makes you
not human what makes us human is our
souls is what we think and empathy and
connecting with people if you can
separate that then you're a lizard okay
so that's true but that's not David's
take David I said they're Ashley lizards
Yeah so basically this is what he says I
actually sat with him and like listen
and like really try to attack on this
podcast I gotta watch that yeah I got
taken down on YouTube but it's something
see they took it down why they gotta
take it down because it's a lizard it's
a lizard get off YouTube Susan I know we
know blink sideways Susan sorry what no
it's my brother's fault actually I made
the title super low-key like like the
global agenda explained you know like
really really chill Gideon's like trying
to up my game goes onto my YouTube and
then he's like the real truth about who
runs the world exposed David Ike no no
no no I was like 24 hours later if it's
[__] why did they remove it say that
again why would they remove it exactly
there's so much misinformation that they
let fly there's only certain types of
misinformation that they continuously
remove yeah I want to hear this lizard
take let me tell you okay fine so
basically he says firstly to consider
that humans are the only
um species um alive in this entire
universe would be really sort of like uh
like human-centric and like egocentric
right ignorant ignorant yeah but it
would be very like self-absorbed to
think that we were the only things on
this universe okay agree that makes
sense I do believe they're like aliens
out there so then he says okay now also
consider the fact that when we see light
like when we see we own we don't see
everything that's actually out there
like you know there's you don't see
music waves you don't see Bluetooth
waves you don't see uh radio waves all
these different things like you don't
see them we only see a certain amount of
things and there are like colors that we
can't even see it talks about cats how
they look around and they see different
things in us no but that's true so yeah
that's the point like we can't see
everything all right so now he says okay
so now consider that these aliens that
are like far away are actually like a
little bit nearer and actually they're
here
and the shape shifting is them going
between light it's like one minute you
see them one minute you don't it's like
you see it and you don't because because
it's like that they're changing form
they're moving from like being able to
be seen in the human spectrum of light
versus like whether like a dog or a cat
could see them like you know when like
cats and dogs are like barking or
meowing at like nothing it's like
because they can see something and the
cat's like pawing though nothing yeah
there's like a ghost or a spirit there
that they can see that's kind of like
the idea so instead of them being in
another dimension they're actually here
physically with us okay and they move
between between Dimensions right that's
why we see them and we don't see them so
he says that these people are non-human
entities maybe lizards I don't know but
they're non-human entities oh he didn't
say lizards specifically his thing is
lizards but he was pretty low-key on my
podcast and like he he kind of like
pulled it back a bit he didn't mention
lizards he was I swear I felt like he
was like trying to like distance himself
from the lizard thing but I don't know
he says these people around the world
they do they do the sacrifices no that
makes sense because there's certain it's
this I sound crazy when I talk about
these rituals and stuff like that but
um my dad's from Haiti and there are
voodoo for example that witchcraft is
real like you zombies for example
the idea of zombies came from Haiti the
original word is called zolbe and they
had potions and they had spells that
they would give to people so that they
would work for 24 hours straight they'd
just be in a conscious working just
working and like pitch black at night
you see people working in the field they
can't even there's no light and they're
still farming so Voodoo is 100 real if
you ask anybody from Haiti or Santeria
and these criminals would they practice
witchcraft they can possess people or
something I've like talked to people
like they shook hands with somebody else
and you can do their Spirit or something
so maybe it's not lizard people but that
type that summoning and possessing your
soul is is a real thing you can you can
conjure evil and there's a lot of people
that have experience with it I
personally haven't had any but I I know
P anybody from Haiti in the comment
section that you know this [__] is real
so maybe that's what he's talking about
I don't know if they're different beings
but that that goes to my theory that you
can separate your soul from your body
and you could become an evil entity that
doesn't care if you do witchcraft if you
practice rituals you practice Satanic
rituals which Voodoo is and which the
pedophiles going in the island are doing
this sort of reminds me years ago I
don't know if you've ever done it but
years ago I did the Ouija board have you
ever done that no don't do satanic [__]
I did it years ago when I was like 16.
are you one of them no but I did it
because my friend's grandfather used to
do it and we were like uh we were in we
were in Spain at the house and they we
just did it why do white people do that
I've never understood that
you guys just like want to get demons in
your life for fun you guys are so bored
they like I was watching the grandfather
and then the girlfriend who looked like
Marilyn Monroe actually like an old man
in Monroe and because that's how she
based herself anyway when you took a
finger off the glass you had to be like
rest in peace something something
something so that the spirit stayed in
the thing it was actually like the most
terrifying thing I've ever seen like I I
swear to God it was legitimately real
like stuff moved and yeah
yeah don't do it I wouldn't recognize it
with that stuff yeah I wouldn't do it
there's a lot of worcestry like psychics
have you ever spoken to us like those
they can really like how they do in the
horror movies they can I've talked to
them one time and they knew a lot of
stuff about me that that nobody knows
and I'm like this is there's you didn't
just read the pause of my hands or
astrology I'm not into astrology that's
all these girls that's why they make no
sense they believe in witchcraft they
believe in the stars and their
personalities align with their chakras
and that's they got crystals
and they can do some [__] bro it's
low-key witchcraft all these girls are a
little bit possessed that's why they're
so easy to predict they don't even
realize that they've been summoned to
think that witchcraft is trendy quirky
yeah I don't know yeah they've glorified
it yeah yeah I don't know that's that's
what made me believe in God that's what
made me try to turn into religion and
live a a Holier life that I'm trying to
strive to because if all this evil is
running the world and God must be out
there are you Christian
I grew up Catholic but I'm leaning more
towards uh Islam now everyone is
I don't know I've always resonated with
it like ever since I was reading Malcolm
X as a little kid actually that's what
red pill me a lot early on was reading
the autobiography of Malcolm X and then
I got really into Santa comedians like I
told you in Dave Chappelle he turned to
Islam and uh resonate with him
and I don't know I have a big Islamic
audience they seem to align with me and
the people that I work with are all
Muslim I don't know it seems just it
speaks to me in a way I wanted to join
the Nation of Islam when I was a kid
because of Malcolm X but apparently it's
a cult it makes no sense but that's just
what what speaks to me the most I I
don't know I never fully resonated with
Christianity to that level I couldn't I
couldn't get on board with it the thing
is I think that all pretty similar like
they are they're just different
variations of the same book and the same
ideas I know yeah but the culture around
it I I do appreciate yeah my best
friend's actually Muslim and I think I'm
Jewish and I think that's why we like
get on so well because you disagree
because we agree on pretty much
everything no we agree well Jews and
Muslims have a lot of beef but we don't
really I feel like we no if you move out
like the politics aside Israel and
Palestine move that away
of course it's the same yeah it is it's
different variations like we we both
work in bless you we both work in crypto
and you know we're like Judaism and she
I'm Jewish she's Muslim we come from
like the same background like family
values you know like forget all this
like weird promiscuity and all this
stuff like we can't like like you know
respecting your father loving your
parents like having close relationship
with your siblings like all this stuff
is comes from like religious foundations
so and I feel like Christy everyone's a
Christian now I saw Tate say that and
it's true like everyone's a Christian
and doing like absurd promiscuous things
so it's if you look at Halloween the
amount of people dressing up as nuns or
like Jesus variations stuff like that
imagine dressing up as Muhammad for
Halloween yeah you don't do that you get
your head chopped it's not gonna it's
not gonna happen yeah so no I think I
think I think all these religions are
very similar if you if you abide by them
like properly
um without the whole Western secular
values and
not the religion that's been infiltrated
by all this westernization and stuff
like that
eventually I have a lot of people in my
stream especially after yay started
talking about about Jewish people have a
lot of especially when people go down
this conspiracy Rabbit Hole there's a
there's a lot of people that from my
chat I've been having to moderate it a
lot because rumble's Pro free speech we
have I've always had people typing in
all caps like about Jews
yeah yeah I mean I'm trying to steer him
away from that yeah here's my take I
feel like I I totally um like I said I'm
very aware of reality I'm not gonna like
pretend that I don't see what what's
happening
um yeah there's a lot of Jewish people
in powerful positions mainly Across
America Jews don't really have this kind
of influence by the way in like England
and stuff like that it's mainly it's
mainly in America
um and I think that they are in powerful
positions but to say that it's Jews that
run the world I think is so surface
level and so ignorant I think that it's
it's the powers at the top and I think
those people at the top top are anything
they're Jews Muslims Christians I don't
even think they have everything even the
majority of the bank owners are Irish I
saw it's not even and most of them
aren't Jewish and what people
misconstrue when they go down the
conspiracy rabbit holes they think that
it's something with Judaism at in its
core which it's not true it's just that
they work together and so that there's a
lot of people at the top that have a lot
of money because they give each other
layups and they give each other deals
and stuff like that back and forth and I
think that the most rich Jews have
bonded together from the trauma of the
Holocaust a mistake that other minority
groups haven't capitalized on black
people should be able to work together
more since slavery and like bond
together like look how the look what
they did to us but instead black people
will quickly shoot each other and work
against each other and operate based off
of ego something that and someone's
gonna clip that up and make me look bad
but Jews don't shoot each other that you
know that's true that's these are all
they do they do yeah which is wild and
in America at least in America
Jews and black people are both
foreigners in America but black people
are the ones at a dice came getting an
argument and then trying to get an ego
battle or calling each other broke or
calling each other or trying to one up
each other a bit to see I'm better than
you and it's not it's it's a system of
capitalism and materialism that has made
people think like that but Jews think
like let's work together to get out of
this like we don't want what happened in
the 30s to happen again so we're gonna
go help each other out and that's not
the same thing Asians haven't Asians are
good at doing that but black people
Spanish people have not used that same
system and I think we should emulate
that yeah I think you I slowly say that
on Tick Tock I think you say it
perfectly I wish Kanye West would be
more eloquent about his his Jewish I had
a good Jew take yeah you have a good you
take yeah as a Jew I approve you have a
good Jew thing yeah yeah I don't think
Kanye West does a tour yeah kind of
comes across kind of badly he didn't
what do you say that was that bad he
said he sounds like he said Jews run the
world like he said it and it's like I'm
not offended it's cool but like it's
just it's you're just not good you know
because
people keep saying to me and I think
it's really annoying people keep saying
to me um
that's a positive stereotype I'm like
number one you're not Jewish you can't
decide whether that's a positive or
negative stereotype number two it's just
not a positive stereotype because we're
talking about Run the World therefore
they are responsible for the bad things
that happen
yeah Hitler's motivation motivation
yes
yes do you want to say it don't come
over no no you're too tired all right
cool okay yeah that was Hitler's
motivation so you're literally like
sparking more more hate and more and
more Violence by saying that when at
first I didn't believe that and then I
saw the reaction because I'm a very big
Kanye supporter I swear I think that he
could have ordered it yes better I
understand the feeling and he he's an
artist so he he operates base and
feelings so he probably felt like he was
screwed over in the music industry in an
entertainment industry so he said I'm
gonna go death count three on you just
kind of like doing a diss track but it's
like you can't don't they're gonna
debank you they're gonna put you in a no
file is be careful so he was operating
based on feeling and thinking that he
could his intentions were good and he
was just responding and could have
worded it better but at first I didn't
believe that he what he said was that
bad and then I've seen the reaction
basically as my chat agrees with me and
I'm like wow wow I had like some debates
with people and then like a lot of them
were joking but they were like w Hitler
WWE is good I'm like well you guys gotta
because if you guys end up in a school
or you end up at a bank or something
like that with an AR and they see that
you were watching my stream
it's it's over you think that my
rumble's gone everything's gone so I've
been trying to communicate and tell them
that what I think is the truth because
when people go down the conspiracy
Rabbit Hole they end up blaming Judaism
a lot of the time even the flat earthers
blamed round earth on on Jews and it's
like
Jews made the killer they made the LIE
up that they're the circular according
to flight or Thursday interesting how
why
I don't know man they're the yamakas
rounds so they want the Earth to match
the hat or some I don't know I I love
all of this stuff I love talking about
the truth behind everything I just I
just don't think it's like the Jews
because if it was I'd be in on it and
like I freaking wish I was in on it like
I wish I had the money I don't have the
money like honestly I want my parents on
an island I should put them in a private
jet but I don't have the money so if
there's any like Jews out there that
want to like let me in the club let me
know you know I'll see what I can do I'm
quite Jewish too sorry let me let me
join 12 something like that 12 Ashkenazi
yeah oh really yeah nice welcome to the
club yeah did you run the world yeah
let's do it all right let's close this
so what would your final message be to
uh you know young men watching
um and something to do with like you
know how to save themselves from
everything that's going on right now all
the propaganda The Matrix and everything
so I would tell them to join my course
the creativity kit it's the
creativitykit.com and
I have a it's a great place to network
and a lot of people have actually got
jobs and have made a lot of money from
those talking to somebody late last
night and he started making five
thousand dollars a month from clients
that he met and through networking from
the creativity kit so I online a course
about how to make money online how to
become a content creator behind the
scenes if you want to edit if you want
to start an online business if you want
to if you're a software engineer and you
want to start making content to funnel
people into your website that's the
place to go I've outlined a course on
that but I understand a lot of people
consider that a scam like this
information is free which is true you
can find that information elsewhere but
what I've built is a great Discord
community in a great place to network
and meet like-minded people because
everybody that I've met that I work with
I've met with online I met I saw your
videos I saw your content everybody that
I work with my editors
um the tape Brothers everything like
that have been through content creation
and a lot of people don't have access to
that so what that gets you is 50 a month
is access to a community where you can
find ways to make money online right now
and people are starting to make
testimonials they were thanking me last
night I was glad to see that because a
lot of people are quick to call it a
pyramid scheme because there's affiliate
marketing they call it a scam because
the information is free but what you
need to do young man is you need to
start making money right now and
everybody understands that the best way
to make money is through an online
business is through content creation is
through the internet because you can do
it anywhere you're free you can use the
internet anywhere you're not locked down
at any place and what they try to do the
past two years was to keep you located
in one spot quarantine shut up lockdown
you can't fly so if you can make money
mobile then you're good so you need to
get rich right now and diversify your
income make sure your money's in
different places because they're
freezing your bank account get as rich
as possible and also be careful about
how red pill do you really get because
you don't want your platforms taken away
before you make money thank you so much
for coming on it's been such a pleasure
thank you
guys please don't forget to hit the like
button and subscribe and we will see you
all next week